I'm roasting you
for the entire world tonight.
The roast fans really
want blood this time,
even though
most of your fans
haven't even gotten
their periods yet.
But if you can take a joke,
then so can the Beliebers
watching tonight,
because face it, Biebs,
you've become
a cocky little shit.
You are the King Joffrey
of pop.
[cheers and applause]
What's your rap name,
Feminem?
Selena Gomez wanted to be here,
but she's dating men now.
Is it true you dumped her
because she grew a moustache
before you?
That's right, Selena Gomez
used to bang this guy,
proving once again
that Mexicans will do
the disgusting jobs
Americans just won't do.
U-S-A! U-S-A!
U-S-A! U-S--